bueno desde el punto de vista del gran
cada vez que han aumentado
su programa nuclear lo han hecho más
fuerte ellos han visto como desde otras
partes del mundo especialmente las
grandes estas grandes potencias con las
que firmaron el acuerdo nuclear han
reaccionado y han buscado tener un
acuerdo con ellos recordemos que ese
pacto nuclear se hizo en el 2015 con el
objetivo de prolongar en el tiempo ese
progreso del programa nuclear y a tener
muchos de esas sectores de ese programa
así que ellos ven que habrán más
necesidades de esos países si realmente
temen como dicen que avances del
programa nuclear iraní usted hablaba de
que ahora enriquecerá el horario al 60
por ciento esté aquí al salto al 90 por
ciento es muy poco y lancia había dicho
que ellos no buscan un programa de
armamento nuclear pero uno de los
objetivos de ese acuerdo nuclear era
hacer que fuera cada vez más difícil que
irán enriquecerá uranio a ese nivel
tanto así que cuando se firmó el acuerdo
había el límite era 3.67 por ciento del
cual obviamente ya pasaron hace
muchísimo tiempo además los otros países
saben que cada vez es más difícil la
posición del gobierno iraní que aunque
quiere volver a ese acuerdo los más
radicales se oponen así que esas
negociaciones de política interna
también son más difíciles para desde el
punto de vista de los países que
negocian con irán
bueno catalina justamente las cifras del
60 por ciento es preocupante el país
está un 30% por debajo de la capacidad
capacidad para armas nucleares va a
despertar estos represalias de israel
bueno las represalias han estado ahí
angela desde siempre recordemos que este
no es el primer sabotaje o ataque contra
el programa nuclear iraní hacer un ayuno
junio del 2020 hubo un incendio un
ataque a la par las plantas exteriores
de esta misma planta de natanz y meses
después fue asesinado que será
considerado por las inteligencias
occidentales como en la cabeza de ese
programa nuclear iraní y ya más atrás
también habían habido más sabotajes o
sea que esto probablemente no será ni el
uno del último de estos ataques de
israel y obviamente que en la medida que
irán va avanzando en ese programa
enriquece uranio a mayor porcentaje
obviamente se siente más nervioso sólo
hace unas pocas horas se anunció que
irán había atacado es lo que se dice son
todavía rumores un barco de israelí de
bandera israelí que estaba en las aguas
del golfo pérsico un poco y que había
aunque los daños fueron pequeños pues
esto es lo que estamos viendo
estamos viendo represalias de un lado d
otro que seguramente van a continuar
gracias catalina